news daily from science mission  researchers evaluated costs for  accelerated aging in cocaine syndrome  model by looking at the mutated DNA  repair enzymes csa or be they show that  CSB brings about oxidative imbalance  resulting in increased expression of  serine protease enzyme which reduces the  levels of fall g1 and catalytic subunit  of mitochondrial DNA enzymes that  results in decreased mitochondrial ATP  production and of course aging next  molecular mechanisms of pancreatic sorry  that in diabetes is poorly understood  but also that expression of micro RNA  200 family he strongly induced in islets  of diabetic mice and that beta cell  specific overexpression of micro RNA 200  in mice is sufficient to induce beta  cell apoptosis and lethal type 2  diabetes via activation of tumor  suppressor trip 53 and bags a apoptotic  protein for more details visitors as www  science mission calm and our Facebook  page thanks for watching